How's it going, guys? Today, I'm going
to be programming second key for my 2016
Chevy Tahoe PPV. When I got this car
from the auction, it only came with one
key, which is typically how it goes. In
situations like this, you should always
make yourself a spare key as soon as
possible. Otherwise, if you lose your
one and only key, it's going to cost you
a lot more to get the new key from a
dealer. But, if you have at least one
working key, the process is going to be
much easier. I got my key online from
this website tommskey.com. The price of
the key was $35 and for additional $60,
they offer key cutting service by photo.
You simply send them a couple pictures
of your existing key and they will cut
same exact copy and ship it to you.
They also sell remotes, keys, and
programming devices for many other car
makes and models. And if you ever have a
need for a spare key, check them out.
You might be able to find what you need.
When I got the keys, I made sure that it
works in the door lock and in the
ignition cylinder, and it worked
flawlessly. They got it right the first
time. Now, I'm going to need to program
this key. And I'm going to try to do it
live on the video so you could see how
this process works. If I turn the key, I
get service theft deterrent system
warning on the dashboard. And if I try
to crank the engine, it doesn't work.
and instead this immobilizer light comes
on and stays on the dashboard.
I also got some key rings from them for
my key and this really cool magnetic key
storage box.
You can use it to hide your second key
somewhere underneath your car and in
case of emergency you can just take it
out, get your spare key, start your car
and drive off. You can also keep your
house key in there. And if you ever lock
yourself out, you will be able to get
back in.
So, let's go ahead and program this new
key.
And just to confirm that it's not
programmed yet, if I try to start the
car, it doesn't work. Let's set it aside
for now.
Now, I'm going to use my original good
working key and start the car.
Next, we're going to need to turn off
the car and within 5 seconds, insert the
new key and turn it into the on
position. We're going to give it a few
seconds to allow it to program the new
key. I think you're supposed to get a
confirmation on the screen that the new
key is programmed, but since I have
other warnings displaying on the screen
currently, I didn't really see that
confirmation message, but if you notice
that immobilizer light is gone, so I
think we should be good now. Let's go
ahead and try to start the car.
And bam, it worked. As you can see, it's
pretty simple and easy process to
program new keys on these Chevys. And
for me, the best part is I didn't even
have to leave my couch. I took a few
pictures, ordered the key online. It
showed up in few days and I was done.
Didn't have to drive to a dealer or
local locksmith, which is really, really
nice. And to make sure it was not a
fluke, let's try to start it again. Here
we go. It works great. We are all set
now. All right. I hope this was helpful.
And if you guys interested in the next
video, I can also show you how to
program remote for your Chevy. Stay
tuned for that. And don't forget to hit
that like button. I put a lot of effort
to make this video easy, simple, and
straight to the point. Thanks. Have a
nice day. Bye.